[Music]
howdy-doo reject nation I'm Greg Alba
here this past weekend I watched a film
a little film called bad times at the El
Royale which is sweeping the box office
right now so you know this video is
gonna get just as many views as our
first man review yeah but hey [ __ ] I
watched it so let's talk about it if
we're going into this I wanted to say
thank you thank you thank you to
everyone who's been following us on the
Stardust app it's a free app to download
a free app to use we post on their
weekly 30-second reactions for any film
TV show or trailer a lot of them are
like micro sketches and such and
actually see this movie but Greg that
was pretty great so check it out yeah
link in the description box probably the
pink comment go ahead down the app write
down let's talk about this movie I
personally have really been looking
forward to this film a lot have you seen
any of our trailer reactions you would
know that I - like the rest of the film
community and the big fan of jus graders
work I actually got into Buffy this past
year been breezing through those seasons
and I really loved his work on daredevil
and yes I really liked the movie cabin
in the woods and knowing he's writing
and directing this film and working with
an ensemble of this caliber of talent
got me very much excited I really enjoy
the hell out of it I did I want to make
that clear before you hear some
criticism it does take a while to find
its momentum and after leaving the
theater it became very apparent that
this film is probably not gonna click in
the same way for everyone at least to
the degree of what people are hoping for
because it's a weird film and if I know
critics I know everyone's gonna be
comparing this movie to the works of
Quentin Tarantino this film feels
exactly like Kill Bill Vol wasn't my
first thought after leaving the theater
was it really felt like the movie
identity except without that weird twist
at the end
meets Tarantino's hateful eight which is
like meeting Reservoir Dogs and meeting
a lot of different segments of Tarantino
movies and this movie's specific plot is
difficult to describe without giving the
story away is like I remember painting
like 15 20 minutes in going what exactly
is this movie about so I'm just gonna
read from what IMDB says cuz you know
how I do seven strangers each with a
secret to bury meet at Lake Tahoe's El
Royale a rundown hotel with a dark past
over the course of one fateful night
every
we'll have a last shot at redemption
before everything goes to hell a pretty
fair way to describe what makes this
film work so well for me specifically
because I'm talking about my point of
view because the opinions are subjective
it's also the area that I noticed some
people are kind of complaining about and
I'd really underline that word kind of
cuz it's in relation to the characters /
performances because everyone in this
film is amazing and I think everyone
would agree that there really isn't one
weak link in this movie and I really
like the approach Drew Goddard in
general takes with his characters but
it's specifically this movie I can't
really go into depth or else it's more
the hell out of the movie oh I thought
was pretty cool and something may be
considered a little gimmicky I
personally didn't each character clearly
resembles a specific type of identity or
personality from the 1960s and it always
comes into play
I actually heard an interview with Drew
Goddard where he was basically saying
that when he worked on a script he
doesn't really think about the Pilate
doesn't think about structure anything
of those things what he mainly thinks
about and puts all his homework into is
the characters their history and he lets
that affect the plot he lets that
determine how everything will unfold and
in this movie especially it really shows
that type of approach does show because
it's one of those movies where pretty
much every character that appears on
screen almost every one of them you get
to see their backstory and it's usually
not upon the initial introduction
usually you have a perception of who
they are from their introduction and
then later on you get their backstory
which leads to a lot of twists a lot of
terms a lot of surprises some deaths
here or there and it really does let the
plot unfold through learning who the
characters are other than the fact that
this film is very dialog heavy another
thing that makes it very Tarantino esque
you know a Tarantino likes to break his
films up into chapters like how he does
with inglorious basterds hateful 8 and
Kill Bill and then he hops around time
doesn't tell stories in a linear way
linear is a word used to describe
structure a lot of times from
screenwriters I noticed so I'm using
that word but the approach that you
gotta takes here instead of calling it
chapters no no no he calls it like room
1 and then you focus on that character
and let the plot go and then room 5 your
operon the characters based off what
room they're in so makes for an
experience where you're like I have to
really pay attention
everything that's going on don't get me
wrong I would love to go into the depth
of these characters when my favorite
things to do when talking about reviews
it's doing a real big analysis of each
character's performance but doing that
here in a non-spoiler review would
ultimately spoil the movie for you if I
were to do that and the trailers do a
really good job at actually hiding those
things because a big part of the fun of
this movie is being unsure where the
plot is going then learning who these
guys are and then that advances the plot
I know it's been a few days films been
out why not just do a spoiler talk I
know but it opened at number seven so a
lot of people are not watching this
movie and when I'm hoping for is that by
the end of this review or maybe even at
this point you are encouraged to go
check this movie out because I think it
deserves more box office numbers the
films are about making money and nothing
else matters Dakota Johnson does a great
job in this film I thought she was
perfect in those 50 shades movies Wow
mwah the man is she's slightly better in
this mess she's I don't like those
movies but she's great in this film
she's got a real tough edge sir and she
actually has a line in this movie that
generated and it's intentional and but
generated one of the biggest laughs from
the theater Jon Hamm is also very
effective in the movie early on him the
film he gets a lot of monologue e to do
in mansi he handles those lines Louis
Pullman plays a guy named miles he's the
dude who's watching over almost every
area of this hotel and he has one of the
more emotional roles in the movie but I
kind of feel like everyone's overlooking
his work in the film but he does a great
job and I think the characters that
everyone's gonna be most gravitated
towards are Jeff Bridges and Cynthia
Reba Jeff Bridges early on in this movie
had a scene that was so effective that
it made me tear up
I know me crimes rare occasion right and
never talked about that
and Cynthia Revo is the one character
that's probably the most relatable and
is arguably the lead if this is an
insomnia and arrow down to who's the
lead character it would be her and damn
is she good I don't know another film
I've seen her and I know she's gonna be
in widow's later this year it made me
want to see more of her she's damn good
and Chris Hemsworth is not in this film
for most of it if you don't know
anything about this film you don't know
Chris Hemsworth in it you won't feel the
bill that's
chris hemsworth but if you know Chris
Hemsworth's in this movie there is that
buildup as an audience for you over
going once chris hemsworth gonna show up
and Wow oh man and skipping in my voice
there when Chris Hemsworth is on screen
he is a mother effing [ __ ] scene
stealer he's charming he's entertaining
at times he is down right scary he is
multi-layered you can't take your eyes
off of him when he's on screen he's not
in it through most like he's important
and when he's there wildly effective and
easily the most intense scene in this
entire film this movie's pretty long but
the most intense scene is one of his
main scenes lengthen movies don't really
bother me but I do think that this film
is Semih I feel like a lot of people
might have stronger opinions about this
I think the film is semi hindered by its
pacing when you watch the trailer for
this film you're gonna expect a really
fast pace snappy perhaps funny like
crime thriller it's not really that
funny it definitely could have been
snappy if there's one argument I agree
with it I don't know if everyone's
saying this but I imagine people would
feel this way is that it probably could
have used a little bit more of a snappy
pacing cuz there is something a little
bit off about it especially in the first
30 minutes of this film because there's
a lot of dialogue happening and it seems
like the pacing and snappiness it seems
like it's all there on paper on script
but there's something in the direction
where it's not quite feeling the
snappiness it's not quite feeling the
energy that I think the film wants you
to feel cuz like I said it seems to all
be on paper and I get the impression
Drew Goddard might have restrained
himself a bit too much in terms of just
letting loose and having a lot of fun
throughout the whole film especially
because there's some reveal at the end
and I love this movie where it could
seem a little strange especially there's
a lot of randomness in this movie the
film starts off and from what the
trailer tells you it would appear
everyone if not everyone most are at
this hotel for the exact same reason as
the film progresses you find out most
are here for entirely different reasons
they just all happen to come together
here on this night that wasn't so much
of a criticism on my end until after I
was leaving the theater and I was like
this is kind of weird how all of these
completely different and that's where
exciting
feels like identity to me you know
before that we're taught to us happen in
the movie and there's this like ending
reveal that happens that I think would
have felt a lot less cheesy and a lot
less like well that's convenient and I
probably wouldn't have felt that way if
the film's pacing had a little bit more
of a sense of fun underlying throughout
the entirety however I really don't want
this to communicate as I thought this
film was slow or I thought it was boring
because I really didn't feel that way I
was very much engaged and pulled in
throughout and there were a lot of
moments where I was like oh [ __ ] that's
cool also my girlfriend had a comment
and if I don't mention that she made the
comment that I'm gonna get crap about
and I know you're watching because I'm
forcing you to watch my video because
I'm doing this by myself
she had a comment that ultimately I do
agree with that even though the
characters are obviously well thought
out and the performances are insanely
solid this story probably would've
worked better as a miniseries as opposed
to a feature film just because some plot
points are left hanging and some are
left in the way of you going yeah we
don't need the answers just leave it a
mystery it kind of works better that way
then there are others where you're like
they just didn't have time to finish up
that storyline because there's a weird
feeling to where when some of the
characters die it's effective it works
with a plot it might just be because the
actors are so good that I didn't want
any of them to actually die but
sometimes when they do die it does kind
of have this like the feeling of being a
bummer like oh I just sort of learn
about their backstory but like I said it
also works because it creates this sense
of anyone can die at any moment all in
all even though I did feel the pacing
could have been a little bit more snappy
I did find it very engaging I really did
enjoy the weird Tarantino s structure I
don't know if he admitted that structure
but it doesn't feel that way of this
film there's plenty of great
performances a lot of nice surprises a
lot of tense moments and I definitely
recommend it and I hope more people go
check this out because it's rare for big
studios to make films like this anymore
especially studios that were just bought
by Disney so you know help them out
anyway guys did you see bad times at the
El Royale who was your favorite
character in the movie comment below
make sure to follow us on the Stardust
app download right now and use it
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell because you know
subscribe buttons
suck